más
anteriormente creaste una pequeña
multitud de robots escogiendo solo
algunas de las combinaciones posibles de
robots regresemos un poco al ejemplo en
el que los robots consistían en una
cabeza y un cuerpo si tenemos dos
cabezas y dos cuerpos entonces podemos
hacer dos por dos igual a cuatro
distintos robots y esto es como poder
escoger entre cuatro posibles actores
pero tu película necesita un elenco de
tres podemos darles nombres a nuestros
actores alice bob carol y dave
a b c y d si los queremos abreviar esto
nos lleva a una pregunta muy interesante
cuantos elencos de tres actores podemos
hacer cuando tenemos cuatro actores de
donde escoger recuerda que para
encontrar cuantas formas hay de combinar
a nuestros actores necesitamos
multiplicar nuestras opciones en cada
una de las etapas en este caso tenemos
cuatro opciones para el primer actor 3
para el segundo y 2 para el tercero
así es que parece que tenemos 4 por 3
por 2 o sea 24 posibles elencos hagamos
una lista de todas las 24 combinaciones
la primera combinación abc significa que
primero escogimos a alice después a
vogue y después a carol pero hay una
pequeña sutileza que tenemos que ver
aquí no hay 24 elencos distintos para
ver dónde está la sutileza observa la
segunda combinación
se ve que significa que escogimos
primero a alice después a carol y
después a bob así es que las primeras
dos combinaciones utilizan a los mismos
actores pero en un orden diferente y
sucede exactamente lo mismo para todas
las otras combinaciones de la primera
caja es el mismo elenco y solo el orden
en el que lo escogimos es diferente en
otras palabras todas las combinaciones
de la primera caja deberían de contar
como un solo elenco de la misma forma la
segunda caja es el elenco que consiste
de alice voz y dave por lo tanto el
número total de elencos es el número de
cajas
así es que cuántas cajas hay en total
como hay seis combinaciones en cada caja
debe de haber 24 entre 6 o sea 4 cajas
así es que hay cuatro elencos pero por
qué sucede que cada grupo contiene
exactamente seis secuencias porque no
tres o cuatro o cualquier otro número el
próximo ejercicio interactivo te va a
ayudar a visualizar este problema usando
algunos otros ejemplos encías que
diviértete mucho